[Music]
Neil welcome to the show thank you thank
you so much I have been hoping to have
this conversation for years and with I
flashback for you know 10 15 20 plus
years I've been reading your work I
can't say that about many people I've
ever met and I mean you've been asking
me incredibly politely um if I could do
the podcasts or anything vaguely you
know such a edging around it and giving
me open invitations for it for a good
decade that's true and I you know and I
love the fact we've managed to do the
occasional tiny goofy thing I got I got
to do read a page of your book that's
right that's right you read a page of
the book which was incredible because I
find your voice as many people do rather
hypnotic and then we got to do a very
short chapter in travel mentors the last
book yeah thank you very much for
answering those questions and it's it's
just such a such a thrill to be able to
spend time with you
I'm loving it and I thought we could
begin with the the glorious beginnings
and maybe for those people who can't see
this I'll give some context I have not
just one recorder but two three four
different sets of audio and that's in
part because I was or em once bitten
twice shy when it comes to audio and
then you shared one of your early days
stories what happened oh so um when I
was 15 I really wanted to meet and talk
to writers and artists I admired and I
couldn't figure out how you did this I
didn't know about conventions if there
were conventions back in 1975-76 so I
had a brilliant idea I would start a
magazine the magazine as far as I was
concerned and even have to exist the
fact that it went on to exist
was really fun and we call it Metro
which was the name I came up with
because it sounded like a magazine
it didn't just sound like a magazine it
sounded like a magazine that you have
heard of and I love the fact that over
the years metro magazines around the
world actually do exist now but in 1975
they didn't but I could phone up and say
what from Metro magazine and people go
oh yeah and you know our voices had
broken so over the phone nobody knew
that we were 15 and I remember
interviewing Michael Moorcock who was an
author whose work I loved with with my
friend Dave Dixon who told me recently
he just found the tape and is
threatening to put it up as some kind of
glorious podcast which I really hope he
does 15 year old Neil Gaiman and Dave
Dixon interviewing Michael Moorcock but
the the one that taught me my lesson was
the I think it was the second interview
we did Moorcock was the first and it was
Roger Dean and Roger Dean is an artist
and designer most famous back then for
the covers of yes albums this beautiful
sort of calligraphy and these floating
islands and things like that and I got
talking to some kid on the train who
said oh yeah you know I know Roger Dean
and so we phoned up Roger Dean's
publisher which was basically Roger Dean
I think they were called Dragon's dream
and said you know like to interview
Roger went down to Brighton
I remember the sheer amazement and joy
of these paintings that were as far as I
was concerned
iconic religious emblem they they were
you know I I and I didn't like yes very
much in fact I didn't really like much
of the music that he done covers too
I had a copy of his book views and just
loved it there was a painting he did up
some badges there was just these things
it felt very Lord of the Rings it felt
very fantastical and there were these
amazing paintings covered in dust
propped up against walls and we
interviewed him and at the end of the
interview I noticed that the tape wasn't
going round and got home played it and
you can hear there's 30 seconds of us
talking there's 30 seconds of us talking
in higher and higher pitched voices
faster and faster like mad chipmunks and
then it stops
yeah and that was the Roger Dean
interview and I and the great thing
about that was when seven years later I
really was a journalist I really was
going around interviewing people I was
interviewing people for magazines that
existed and you know had existed before
we decided to do the interviews and
things um I was carried spare batteries
I always carried spare tapes if I could
you know at the point where I could
afford to I even carried a spare micro
cassette recorder just in case just in
case two is one and one is none as they
say sometimes and so the gods the gods
gifted you with a malfunction early
exactly one good malfunction and you
learn your lesson that pain thing and we
were chatting before we sat down to
record as I was gathering copious
beverages water and tea and and so on
for us I'm using the Royal ass I suppose
mostly for me and water and we're
talking about this location downtown
where we're sitting and I've I've
decided in the last few years to use
locations outside of my home for a lot
of what I do because I've found it
that is it being sitting at my kitchen
table doing a lot to sometimes produce
Himalayas this is the odd Association or
lack of dissociation between work and
home and I had read at one point that
Maya Angelou and I hope I'm getting that
pronunciation right would rent hotel
rooms to work on a lot of her writing
and then you brought up another name so
um back in about 1997 I read an article
by Ian Fleming he wrote the James Bond
books about how he wrote the James Bond
books and you read this article and you
realize something which is Ian Fleming
did not enjoy the process of writing I
was always fascinated by the fact that
that several of Roald Dahl's most famous
short stories were plotted by Ian
Fleming Ian Fleming would really yeah he
gave Dahl no idea the two best short
story twists which are lamb to the
slaughter where the woman kills her
husband with a leg of lamb and then
cooks it and feeds it to the detective
who is going I cannot figure out what he
was hit with is an Ian Fleming plot and
so is the one about the evil antique
dealer who finds this amazing antique in
you know on some farm and decides to
cheat the farmers and explains that well
the thing isn't worth any money but the
legs the legs are worth some money so
I'll I'll give you a you know twenty
quid for the legs and is about to take
away this million pound antique thing
and the farmers helpfully rip off the
legs and throw the rest of it away who
makes easier for you and and those plots
were both the in planning's and you
start realizing I you really don't like
writing when you read his thing on how
he wrote the James Bond books
you ride a James Bond book in two weeks
you check into a hotel you have to check
into a hotel somewhere that you don't
want to be otherwise you might go out
and walk around a become a tourist you
have to check into a not terribly nice
hotel room otherwise you might luxuriate
and enjoy it and instead what you want
to be is focused on getting out and then
you having nothing else to do in this
town in this place you settle down and
you write like a fiend and you get your
James Bond book written and who peeks
and you leave this horrible hotel room
and that was how he did it and I have
tried it a couple of times I did it with
the American draft of never where that
was the first one I ever tried and I did
the entire set of American draft which
was a big second era the book had
already been published in the UK but my
American editor wanted stuff done
because she pointed out that the book as
it existed was written for people whom
you knew that Oxford Street was a big
Street with lots of shops on it and you
know or whatever they was written for
Brits and Londoners and she wanted
something expanded so I expanded it and
I was in a room with as far as I
remember no windows in the I think it
was a Marriott in the World Trade Center
and which is no longer there but writing
in that hotel room you just wanted to be
out it's it seems to me and you can't
believe everything you read on the
Internet so I want you to certainly fact
check me as needed but that you you also
have or have had some internal rules so
you can you can use your external
environment to assist but but I
that and again feel free to correct not
making rules the importance of making
rules rules like you can sit here and
write or you can sit here and do nothing
but you can't sit here and do anything
else that that was always and still is
when I go off to write that's my biggest
rule could you speak to that yeah cuz I
would go down to my lovely little gazebo
at the bottom of the garden sit down and
I'm absolutely allowed not to do
anything I'm allowed to sit at my desk
I'm allowed to stare out at the world
I'm allowed to do anything I like as
long as it isn't anything not allowed to
do a crossword not allowed to read a
book allowed to phone a friend not
allowed to you know make a claim model
of something I all I'm allowed to do is
absolutely nothing or right and what I
love about that is I'm giving myself
permission to write or not write but
writing is actually more interesting
than doing nothing after a while you
know you sort of sit there and you've
been staring out the window now for five
minutes and it kind of loses its charm
well actually might as well write
something and and it's hard
I'm as a writer I'm more easily
distractible I have a three-year-old son
he is the epitome of cuteness and charm
he's it's more fun playing with him than
it is writing which means if I'm gonna
be writing I need to do it somewhere
where I don't have a three-year-old some
singing to me asking me to read to him
demanding my attention and I think
that's a I think it's a really just a
solid rule for writers it's like yeah
you don't have to write you have
permission to not write
but you don't have permission to do
anything else it reminds me of another
one of my favorite writers you being the
one who's sitting in front of me John
McPhee nonfiction writer who has spent
much of his life in Princeton New Jersey
but has written some incredible pilled
surprise winning nonfiction and I was
lucky enough to take class with him a
thousand years ago and his his rule was
very similar they didn't state it
explicitly he would sit in front of his
first as a young man type writer he
could sit in front of the blank page and
from 8 a.m. to 6 p.m. with the exception
of a break for lunch and swimming
it was the blank page or writing its
disallowed from doing anything else are
there any other rules or practices that
you also hold sacred or important for
your writing process ah some of them
just things for me for example most of
the time not always I will do my first
draft in fountain pen because I actually
enjoy the process of writing with the
fountain pen I like the I like filling a
fountain pen
I like uncapping it I like the weight of
it in my hand I like that thing so I'll
have a notebook I'll have a fountain pen
and I'll write if I'm doing anything
long if I'm working on a novel for
example I will always have two fountain
pens on the go at least with two
different colored inks at least because
that way I can see at a glance how much
work I did that day I can just look down
and go look at five pages in brown eye
that I wrote that half a page in black
that was not a good day nine pages in
blue
was it what a great day and I you can
just sort of get a sense of okay are you
are you working are you making forward
progress what's actually happening and I
also love that because it emphasizes for
me that nobody is ever meant to read
your first draft your first draft can go
way off the rails your first draft can
absolutely go up in flames it can you
can change the age gender number of a
character you can bring somebody dead
back to life nobody ever needs to know
anything that happens in your first
draft is you telling the story to
yourself and then I'll sit down and type
and I'll put it onto a computer and as
far as I'm going to send the second
draft is where I try and make it look
like I knew what I was doing all along
do you edit then as you're looking or
translating from the first draft on the
page to the computer or do you get it
all down as is in the computer and then
edit okay no I definitely that's my
editing process I think that's my second
draft is typing into the computer and
also I love so backing up a bit here
when I was what was I 27 28 in the days
when we were still in typewriters and
there were just a handful of people with
word processors which were clunky things
with discs which didn't hold very much
and stuff I edited an anthology and
enjoyed editing mines don't you most of
the stories that came in were about
3,000 words long move forward in time
not much five six seven years mid 90s
everybody is now
on computer and I edited another short
story anthology and the stories that
were coming in tended to be somewhere
between six and nine thousand words long
and they really have much more story
than the three thousand words ones and I
realized that what was happening is it's
it's a sort of a computer thing is if
you're typing putting stuff down is work
if you've got a computer adding stuff is
not work choosing his work so it sort of
expands a bit like a gas if you have two
things you could say you say both of
them if you have this stuff you want to
add you add it and and I thought okay I
have to not do that because otherwise my
stuff is gonna balloon and it will
become gaseous and thin so what I love
if I've written something on a computer
and I decide to lose a chunk it feels
like I've lost work if I delete a page
and a half I feel like there's a page
and a half it just went away and that
that's a page and a half worth of work
I've just lost if I've been writing in a
notebook I'll I'm typing it up and I can
look at something go I don't need this
page and a half and I leave it out I've
just saved myself work and it feels kind
of like I'm I'm treating myself so I'm
just trying to always have in my head
the idea that maybe I'm somehow on some
cosmic level paying somebody by the word
in order to be allowed to write that
that if they're there they should matter
they should mean something it's always
important to me and you mentioned you
mentioned distraction earlier and you're
dangerously adorable son which which I
certainly agree with
I had read somewhere actually before I
get to that this might seem like a very
very mundane question but what type of
notebooks do you prefer they large like
legal pads are they leather-bound what
type of notebooks when they came out I
really liked I've used a whole bunch of
different ones I bought big drawing ones
which actually turned out to be a bit
too big all I kind of liked how much I
could see on the page those were the
ones I wrote Stardust and and American
Gods in sort of big size but they
weren't terribly portable I went over to
the mall skins and I loved them when
they first came out and then they
dropped their paper quality and dropping
paper quality doesn't matter unless
you're writing and fountain pen because
all of a sudden it's bleeding through
and all of a sudden you're writing on
one page leaving a page blank because
it's bled through and writing on the
next page and Joe Hill about six or
seven years ago Joe Hill the wonderful
horror a fantasy writer suggested the
Elector to me and so my usual notebook
right now is a low-key term because I
really like the the way you can paginate
stuff in them and the thickness of the
paper and they're just like sort of mole
skins but but the Porsche of moles is
just better and I also have been writing
I wrote the graveyard book and I'm
writing the current novel in a these
beautiful books that I bought in a
stationery shop in Venice
[Music]
built into a bridge some are in Venice
there's that there's a little stationery
shop on a bridge and they have these
beautiful leather-bound blank books that
just look like hardback books but
they're blank paper pages and I wrote
the graveyard book in one of those I
bought four of them and now I'm using
the next one on the next novel and it
may well go into another one I'm not
sure and then at home in a except at
home my house in Wisconsin which is
where my stuff is you know I broke up my
we live in Woodstock but I have an
entire life's worth of stuff still
sitting in my house in Wisconsin and it
it's become archives it's you know it's
actually kind of fabulous having a house
that is an archive but waiting for me in
that house is a book that I bought for
myself about 25 years ago and before I
die I plan to write a novel in it and
it's an Accounts book from the mid 19th
century it's 500 pages long every page
is is numbered it's lined with accounts
lines but very faint so it'll be nice to
write a book in it and it is engineered
so that every single page lies flat and
it's huge and it's heavy and it just
looks like a book that you know Dickens
or somebody would have written a novel
in and I've just been waiting until I
have an idea that is huge and weird and
Dickensian enough and whether or not I
actually get to write it in the pen
I'm not sure but I definitely want to
write it in a
sort of old Victorian something slightly
copper plating one of those old flex nib
pens that they stopped making when
carbon paper came in just so I can get
that kind of spidery Victorian
handwriting I'm just imagining you
putting pen to the first page when you
finished the first page and what that
will feel like that's gonna be a good
day it will it will be either a good day
or an incredibly bad day okay at the end
of the first page ah no I have this
pristine but it is it is the the thing
that I tell young writers and by young
writers a young writer can be any age
you just have to be starting out which
is anything you do can be fixed what you
cannot fix is the perfection of a blank
page but you cannot fix is that pristine
unsullied whiteness of a screen or a
page with nothing on it because there's
nothing that affects you mentioned a
word and it might be that I'm a little
slow moving because I'm from Long Island
but lysed um how do you spell that la le
i CH I think is T URM and then 1917 I
think is that that twitter handle is
definitely like tome 1917 them and I'll
put that in the show notes for folks so
you'll be able to find it
since you gave me but I'm not intending
to turn this episode into a shopping
list but I've never used fountain pens
really I have not and my assistant my
dear assistant does she loves using
found fence she enjoys the act I've had
a few sloppy false starts and then been
rather impatient but if I wanted to give
it a shot are there any particular
fountain pens or criteria that you would
use in picking um a good pen you know
the biggest criteria I would use in
picking if you have the choice is go
somewhere
like New York's fountain-pen Hospital is
that a real place it's a real place it's
called the fountain pen hospital they
sell lots of new pens they recondition
all pens they look after pens for you
and try them out because the lovely
thing about fountain pens is they are
personal you you you go no no no and
then you find the one I tend to suggest
to people who are just nervously you
know I've never used a fountain pen what
should I do and I will point them at
Lummi la my who have some fabulous
starter pens and they're not very
expensive and they're good they do a pen
call they love the Safari but they have
a bunch of good good starter pens and
they're just nice to to get into the
idea of do I like doing this
the let's see what am I using right now
I got in here I've got so this one here
is a pilot
it's a nummy key and it's a flexi nib
ever-so-slightly when you put down
weight on it the the nipples spread it's
a beautiful beautiful pen though that
one's a propellant I think this one here
is than amici and it's really weird
because no Miki is pilots I don't quite
understand that this is maybe it's a
sort of Toyota Lexus thing I think it is
it's that kind of thing
this one here is called a falcon and
again you put a little bit of weight on
it and the line will just spread and
thicken which is part of the fun of
fountain pens and I will just you know
I'll go and play
there's a lovely
Talya man I got my eight my agent I did
a thing some years ago when I realized
that I was losing a lot of actual
writing time to signing foreign
contracts and this is for books this is
for books or occasional ink you know for
stories or things being reprinted around
the world and the contracts would come
in and there would be big sheaves of
them because I get printed all around
the world and foreign contracts a lot of
them you have to sign a lot you have to
do a lot of initialing and and I would
sit there going I have just spent ninety
minutes
signing a pile of contracts and I love
that I got to sign it but so I contacted
my agent I said can I give you like
power of attorney but do you mind just
can you just sign these things for me
and she's like absolutely great so I got
her she'd never used a fountain pen and
I got her a fountain pen I actually went
to the New York fountain pen hospital
with her and did the thing of showing
her pens you know what do you like come
then and I got her a Visconti which is
just these lovely Italian pens and
mostly I love this sort of a slightly
fetishistic bit of having bottles of
beautifully colored ink when you start
talking to fountain pen people they
really they pretend to be interested in
what pen you like but they don't care
because they found their own pens that
they love and they said what are you
used and I you know I use pilot eight to
threes for signing and and I actually
now I bought a pilot eight to three
because it's just a fantastic signing
pen it's a workhorse it keeps going and
I got one in 2012 and it was my signing
pen I signed through ocean at the end of
the lane you know before the book had
come out
I'd already pre signed you know written
my signature 20,000 times with this pen
I've seen footage of you icing your hand
after signings that was the signing tool
that I really got into icing my hand
because and wrist and arm and you know I
I did the numbers and as far as I can
tell I have signed about one and a half
million signatures with that pen which
remained and I had to send it off to
Pilate at one point not because the nib
was in trouble because the the plunger
mechanism was starting to stick and they
fixed it for me and sent it back and
then my three-year-old son found a place
behind a cast iron fireplace in our
house in Woodstock where if you just
insert your father's pilot 8310 which
you have found on the table just to see
if it would go in there you can actually
guarantee that nobody without
disassembling the house and we actually
have to take the entire house apart to
uninstall a cast iron fireplace from
1913 to get at the Pens how come that is
that pen now has been given as a
sacrifice in the house God so I need to
get a new one it strikes me at least it
seems as we're talking that many of the
decisions you've made the tools you've
found and enlisted act to make not
writing unappealing or at least boring
after five minutes and to into sort of
enhance the act of writing to make it
something that is enjoyable I don't I
don't know that stret is true and but
they also exist for another reason which
is kind of weird which is to try and
trivialize what I'm doing and not make
it important and Freight it down with
wait because that paralyzes me when I
started writing I had a typewriter
it's a manual typewriter when I sold my
first book I had the money to buy an
electric typewriter what was that first
book all right gosh I actually don't
remember whether I bought the electric
typewriter with the money from a book
called ghastly beyond belief look of
science fiction and fantasy quotations I
did with Kim Newman or whether I did it
whether it was for that your and your
own biography that I did either way I
was just 23 and and what I would do back
then is I would do my rough draft on
scrap paper single spaced so that it
couldn't be used and also so that I
could get as many words on and you know
paper was expensive and then so so I
could always do that and I remember the
joy of getting my first computer and
just the idea that I wasn't making paper
dirty nothing mattered until I press
print and that was absolutely nutley
liberating and then you know a decade on
picking up a notebook it was for
stardust of which I decided that I
wanted the rhythms have Stardust to be
sort of very antiquated rhythms and I
thought I there's probably a difference
to the way that one writes with a
fountain pen
17th century writing 17th 18th century
writing you notice tends to go in very
very long sentences and long paragraphs
and I my theory about this is that one
reason why you get this is because
you're using dip pens and if you pause
they they dry up so you just have to
kind of keep going it forces you to do a
kind of writing where you're just again
for a very long sentence and you're
gonna get over a long paragraph and
you're gonna keep moving in this thing
and you're sort of thinking ahead with
if you're writing on a computer you'll
think of the sort of thing that you mean
and write that down and then look at it
and then fiddle with it and get it to be
the thing that you mean if you're
writing in fountain pen if you do that
you just wind up with a page covered
with crossings out so it's actually so
much easier to just sort of think a
little bit more you slow up a bit but
you're thinking the sentence through to
the end and then then you start writing
you write that and then you pause then
you write the next one at least that was
the way that I hypothesized I might be
writing and I wanted start us to feel I
could have been written in the late
1920s and I thought well to do that I
should probably get myself a fountain
pen and a book and that so that was how
I started writing that and again what I
loved was suddenly feeling liberated was
like ah I'm not actually making words or
not going down in phosphor on a computer
screen the this trivializing is
I think very very important and I'd love
to dig into it a little bit because this
is something that's come up quite a bit
initially very unexpectedly with with
people I interview on the podcast and
we're having conversation with Sean
white in a legendary snowboarder and I
asked him what he said to himself what
was his internal monologue or dialogue
right before the gate opened for the
last run in the Olympics for the gold
medal and his answer was who cares
yeah which surprised me and he said yeah
because I in effect you know if I apply
an incredible amount of weight to myself
it's going to do nothing but handicap me
and you do see or are there many
examples of of writers of musicians who
have sort of crumbled with sophomore
syndrome after a success and had great
difficulty put it putting out work
you've put out a lot of very very good
work I've read and listened to and
watched a lot of your work what are
other things you do to remove that
weight if anything other things you say
to yourself when you commit to writing a
book when you when you sign the
agreement with the publisher for yet
another novel is there any other advice
that you would give or any other things
that you do that help to remove the sort
of psychological performance anxiety
well if you're me you tend to do the
things that are not actually financially
sensible but make life easier
I write unlike writing things then
nobody's waiting for it's much more
stressful writing things that people
actually are waiting for that people
care about it's why it felt wonderful to
follow American gods up with Coraline
nobody even knew that I wanted to be a
kids author and it was an odd kind of
thing to be and I've just written this
giant novel that's won all of the awards
and it's incredibly adult and it's thick
and it's a proper book and look I got
the Hugo and look I got the nebula and
so on and so forth and then here's the
book nobody's waiting for about did you
work on see you worked on that before
anyone knew you in other words you
hadn't set expectations carline was
written
I thought Caroline was unpublishable and
that I was told it was initially and I I
started it for my kids my daughter in
particular Holly I showed it to an
English editor who told me it was
completely unpublishable we moved to
America the idea was that I was writing
in my own time but I didn't have any own
time somewhere in there I sent it to my
friend Jane Yolen
I mentioned to Jane there was an amazing
children's author but also at the time
was editing a line of books and she
showed it to she wanted to buy it and
the people upstairs the publishing house
said absolutely not and and you know
this was just the first third of
Coraline that hadn't even got bad yet
and I like put it away and then a few
years on I looked around and realized I
now had another daughter I now had
Maddie and she was a baby and she was
getting bigger and if I didn't finish
that book you know is this book I
started for Holly and now Holly's too
old almost and and I needed to finish it
so I sent it to my new editor but I sent
it to my a doubt editor I didn't have a
children's editor Jennifer Hershey at
China remember where we at HarperCollins
at the time or was it still Avon I think
it was still Avon yet Ben Avon got
bought by HarperCollins which is how I
became a
HarperCollins author um and she read it
and she called me up and she said this
is great what happens next and I said
send me a contract and we will both find
out so bless her she did and so I went
back to writing it because now it was
actually something that actually had a
delivery date attached and I did not
have the time to write it in it wasn't
like I have more time and I remember
what I did was I had a notebook by the
side of my bed and instead of reading
three or four pages a night and then
turning off the light and gonna sleep I
would write maybe fifty words of
Coraline which doesn't seem much right
before bed right before bed so I wasn't
right a reading before bed I was just
writing before bed but I got a bed and I
would reread what I'd written on
Caroline and I would do you know five or
six lines of Caroline but if you do it
that way you know you've written a page
a week and so it it kept moving forward
and then we went on a cruise a
fundraising cruise for the comic book
Legal Defense Fund which is a First
Amendment thing and I was working on
American Gods and I did not pack due to
a packing error the American Gods
notebooks but I did have the Caroline
book with me so on that cruise I got to
write quite a bit more Coraline and then
a couple of months later I was done the
despair of ever finishing American Gods
because I've been writing it by that
point for at least 18 months and figured
that I had about a year to go and just
said
and wrote Coraline and just finished it
and sent it off to my publisher and it's
like here is a book you can publish this
and they're like that's great but we
will wait for American guys do you tend
to work on multiple projects at once
they used it I used to be really good at
working on multiple projects at once I
think I have to start I think I have to
start accepting that I'm not as good
anymore
I packed what does that mean
it means that in the old days when I was
young I would have at least three things
on the go which was great because if I
got stuck on any one of them I would do
the other even when I was writing
American Gods
I would always have the next of the sort
of the coming to America short stories
in my head so if I got stuck on shadow I
would just take a week and I do one of
the coming to America stories and then I
go back to shadow again and but these
days I don't think I'm as good at that
anymore
I I think I am I think it's great to
have three or four things going on but
there is that point I start looking at
myself and going actually I'm getting
less done I'm not doing that thing where
I get stuck on project day so I just
immediately
snip over a project B it takes me a
little ramping up time to get to the
headspace now project B and at the point
where I have project a B C and D all
waiting for me what I do is look at them
make a noise like lurch from The Addams
Family you know others Oh kind of noises
like often make a cup of tea and a plate
with a Shore something so I think
actually I it's one of those things we
just know thyself
I think I now have to start going now
just just one thing at a time
it also means I'm gonna have to say no
to more introductions and things yeah
cuz and I love doing introductions I
intentions you mean writing introduction
writing introductions writing
introductions to other people's work
writing introductions and essays and
things where you go here is the thing I
love I wanna I can get it to the world I
can tell people why I love this thing
and maybe they'll discover it and every
now and then and you know sometimes you
know your introduction makes no real
difference in the scheme of things and
then sometimes you know James Thurber I
was told I could bring you know that
that they would bring them the 13 clocks
back in the print if I wrote an
introduction to it so it's like yes I'm
writing an introduction to it and then
because it has an introduction by me
I've run into many hundreds of people
who I assume are representatives of
thousands of people over the years who
said you know I picked up that book
because your name was on the cover and
oh my god it's become my favorite book
you know I read it to my kids it's
amazing and I go good that's that's what
it's for that's why you do this you
mentioned writing right before bed I'd
love to talk about the maybe not the
scheduling but the timing of writing so
I was was doing prep for this
conversation and came across an
interview in which you said that for for
nonfiction you can kind of write
wherever it happens to fall if it's a
script or something else but that for
novels very often you tend to write
between say 1 and 6 p.m. where you'll
handle email maybe writing a blog post
and so on in the morning and I'd love to
chat about that because many of the
writers I've spoken to and I'm sure it's
it differs person to person but tend to
write either very late or very
because they feel like they avoid
distractions when I started out from
from the age of about 22 when I was a
young journalist 2627 a starting out
comics writer you know on all through
there I was a like late late night
writer nothing really happened until the
kids were in bed 9 o'clock
I might have factored out a little bit
during the day but now it's all done and
now I'm getting down to work and at 2 or
3 o'clock in the morning and I'm writing
in England at this point I'm a phone a
friend in America just to talk enough to
make sure that I'm awake
but so that's what I did and and I was a
smoker and a coffee drinker and it was
great I moved to America in 92 gave up
smoking 93 stopped drinking coffee went
over to tea and tried being a late-night
right trying carrying on being a
late-night writer and gradually realized
that I wasn't really any more what
tended to happen was somewhere around
1:00 in the morning I'd be writing away
and then I would lift my head from the
keyboard at 4 o'clock in the morning and
have 3,000 pages of the letter M just go
okay that this doesn't really work
anymore for me and then I started
rescheduling trying different things out
part of
what I discovered particularly about
being a novelist is writing a novel
works best if you can do the same day
over and over again the closer you can
come to just Groundhog Day you just
repeat that day you you set up a day
that works for yourself you know I I the
last novel that I actually wrote I was
at Tori Amos is wonderful house in
Florida she has this lovely sort of
house on the water that she's lent me
many times to go and write in and I went
down there and I would get up in the
morning I would go for a jog come back
do my yoga get dressed and and get in
the car drive down to a little cafe
where there were just enough people
around that I knew that other people
existed but nobody that I would ever be
tempted to talk to and I would order
myself kappab large cup of green tea sit
in the corner and just start writing and
I would do that day over and over and
over and over and you know a couple of
months later looked up and and I had the
ocean at the end of the lane which was
only meant to have been a short story
anyway it just kept going and I add that
I think works really really well I also
think that the the most important thing
for human beings is to be aware of the
change you know the the biggest problem
we run into is going this is who I am
this is what I'm like this is how I
function while failing to notice that
you don't do that anymore
I'm perfectly aware that I may one day
become one of those people who wakes up
early in the morning and goes and writes
my friend Jean wolf who is now in his
late 80s and is one of you know and the
finest writers that America has for
years was a an editor of a magazine
about factories I think was called plant
engineering and so he'd get up at four
o'clock in the morning and write for an
hour before anything else before the day
started before he had to leave for work
and before anybody else was up and that
was how he did it
I cannot imagine getting up in the
morning and just writing that's not how
my head works I need a while to get here
but I can absolutely imagine that one
day I'll all have become one of those
morning writers from having been a late
night writer in my youth and an
afternoon writer in my in my middle-age
in my dotage I could absolutely become a
morning writer
in your dotage I think that's gonna take
a while I do want to ask you a question
related to a name that came up a little
earlier and that is and this of course I
think I'm getting right because comes
from a reliable source which is your
blog and my blog is a pretty reliable I
think it's very reliable and for those
those who know your work outside of the
blog it really encouraged to read some
of your work on the blog there's some
really touching personal work one in
particular about your gorgeous white dog
whose name I'm currently just in such a
beautiful piece that in fact I owe you
thanks for because it led in part there
are many factors but to me getting my
first dog as an adult Molly which I put
off for decades so thank you for that
but this
question beautiful piece this is related
to Holly so and I'm gonna use this as a
very sneaky way to ask you a question
that you'd probably dislike being asked
and it involves 57 year olds so my
understanding is you're convinced to
speak to your daughter's class about
where ideas come from and what I what I
noted here I'm not going to ask it that
way but the line that stuck out was you
get ideas when you ask yourself simple
questions
well what if dot-dot-dot what if you
woke up with wings if only if only real
life was like it is in Hollywood
musicals I wonder dot dot if this goes
on this is one I really liked you know
if this goes on telephones are going to
start talking to each other and cut out
the middleman wouldn't it be interesting
if thought thought into the the question
I'm going to ask is a follow-up it
doesn't have to map perfectly to this
but I would love to hear the genesis
story of the graveyard book and the
reason I ask you about that book
specifically is that it is my my
absolute favorite fiction audio book of
all time and so this is I remember the
exact moment when I finished the
graveyard book in audio and there are
multiple versions people who ask me I
have not listened to the ensemble
version and - I'm sure it's spectacular
but not not to sound creepy I do find
your voice very soothing and I finished
it as my plane was not my plan let me
rephrase as a plane was landing and a
few minutes before we landed and I
thought about restarting the book so
it's it's had a wonderful place in my
heart in my mind where did that book
come from - I can give a slightly better
answer to that now
and I could have done a year ago or I
have done for previous years because I
found something accidently recently
which was which gave me an insight in
the
so I was 25 years old
it would have been 1984 85 maybe even 18
26 I was living in Sussex in a little
town in a very tall house my dad owned
the house
actually what he owned was a shop
underneath but the house sort of cane
came with it and because little old
English towns go back for a long time
the house was at least 300 years old and
it was across a little lane from a
country graveyard and the house was
incredibly tall and incredibly thin you
get a couple of rooms and then he gets
tears and I had a son who at that point
was two years old and his favorite thing
was his little tricycle and the problem
of little tricycles is you cannot ride
them around houses like that otherwise
you die hit the stairs and you die so
every day I would take him and his
little tricycle over the road to this
little churchyard and he would pedal
happily round and round the paths
through the gravestones and I remember
just the the thought process I remember
going he looks so happy here looks
really comfortable there is something
very sweet about a little kid riding a
tricycle through a graveyard and I
thought I could do a story about it
wouldn't it be fun to do a story about
that you could do a story like it will
be like you know a kid in a graveyard
getting brought up by dead people and
then I thought actually
Kipling already kind of did that once
with the jungle book which is a kid in a
jungle being brought up by wild animals
and teaching him the things that wild
animals know so I would have to have a
kid in a graveyard being taught the
things that dead people know and I went
up to my office my little office sat
down at my typewriter and started to
write now when I told people this in the
past I've said I wrote a couple of pages
and realized that it wasn't good enough
and I was wrong I actually wrote an
entire first chapter I discovered
because about a year ago looking for
something else I found it and wasn't
very good what was fascinating and
delightful about it was the portrait of
the kid which was very obviously a
really actually looking back in a quite
good pen portrait of my son Mike who is
now a that you did that you know I'm
describing the baby and I only knew one
so so it's Mike and that was really
interesting but story doesn't work and I
think I forget I think I've got a this
is there's a demon in it I don't have
who I think is the person who winds up
being the person who kind of accepts him
into the graveyard you know nothing's
quite right but there's a central idea
there but I wrote I remember writing
that and just going okay this is a
better idea than I am a writer so I need
to put this off and about
a decade later I came back tried it
again and this time you know at least
according to memory it was only a couple
of pages and again I went oh no still
not good enough for this may I pass for
one sec yeah you must have ideas for
potential stories all the time yeah but
this was different this was one where I
knew I knew it had legs and I knew it
was real and I knew it was good and in
fact you know it was interesting there
was a point where I thought I wasn't
gonna do it and I kind of gave the idea
to Terry Pratchett we've been we've had
our photos taken in a graveyard and with
we were talking about graveyards and
kids and I said well there's this book
that I was gonna write and this is what
I was gonna do in it and what is lovely
is Terry didn't do any of that exactly
but he took he wrote a book called
Johnny and the dead which was sort of
taking some of the stuff but it wasn't
close enough that I couldn't then still
do my story but what was great sigh I
knew that this was still important and I
still wanted to tell the story and over
the years I would just let it accumulate
and finally in about 2003 I finished
writing I think it was a Nancy boys
which I also listened to an eye on audio
haha Lenny Henry is brilliant rattle
incredible such a great read and I got
to the end of a Nancy boys and I thought
you know I I don't think I'm getting any
better
I think this is now as a writer um
probably me it's probably it I may
improve you know tiny bit but it's not
going to be the leaps and bounds that I
know
I was so I have absolutely no excuse for
putting off the graveyard book but when
I've started the other two times and it
didn't work I started with chapter one
I'm gonna start right in the middle and
I wrote the first two pages of of the
witch's headstone chapter four and did
emotionally exactly the same thing I
always do I had always done at that
point with the graveyard book we just
got such is not good enough it's not
good enough my daughter Maddie because
at this point we're on we're in the
Cayman Islands
on a small holiday me Maddie and Holly
Maddie comes out the sea wanders over to
me and says what what are you doing
I said I'm writing a story she's read it
to me so I read her the first page and a
half that I'd written and she said what
happens next
so I kept going and I think I would I
would absolutely have been capable of
giving up and failing at that point
except Maddie wanted to know what
happened next
so I kept writing and by the end of that
I'd written a story that felt like it
worked
I had the tone I had the voice I had
Silas I had all of that stuff when it's
right here by the way I'm so lovely
Silas and then I started at the
beginning and I and the the the one
thing that I have no idea where it came
from because it was just sitting in the
notebook when I came to start it's like
I'd written it at some point in the
previous five years knowing that it
would be you know knowing that I would
have to start at some point was just the
line there was a hand in the darkness
net hold a knife
and knowing that that was the first line
of the story and feeling kind of you
know having very mixed feelings about
that because going well on the whole
this story is gonna be very loving it's
gonna be very tender it's gonna be about
growth it's gonna be about families it's
gonna be about villages it's gonna be
about people but the first few pages are
going to be absolutely terrifying
and that was the first line yeah I think
you did you've certainly delivered on
the first few pages being very very
terrifying I'm gonna go back and listen
to that again maybe I'll try ensemble
this time around the ensemble is real I
mean you know I and I'm not just saying
this because for me you know listening
to one of my own audiobooks it's a lot
like back when you were young and we had
answering machines and you would be
listening to messages people had left
for you and then you'd suddenly hit your
own voice and it's like no I don't sound
like that
but I but it's Derek Jacobi who is one
of England's greatest actors as the
narrator you the cast of people like
Miriam Margolies Rhys Shearer Smith just
this fabulous cast so you mentioned your
name that I was planning on bringing up
anyway and that is Terry Pratchett yeah
and I think many people who at least in
the United States are less familiar with
Terry than perhaps they should be could
you tell us who Terry is and how you
first met Terry Pratchett later Sir
Terry Pratchett was an English writer
who died in March 2015 he was a humorist
a satirist best known for the Discworld
novels set on a flat earth
which is on the back of four elephants
on the back of an enormous turtle
swimming through space and he was my
friend Terry and I met when his first
book first Discworld book the colour of
magic was due to come out in paperback
and we met for years and years we would
tell everybody that we met in a Chinese
restaurant and again a few years ago I
found my desk diary from 1985 and I
thought ah there's Terry and me meeting
in February 1985
I wonder which Chinese restaurant it was
and it turned out we actually met on
like the 28th of January and it was Bert
or Ellie's Italian restaurant in Goodge
Street I think it was good street
proving that memory is gloriously
fallible embarrassingly so since I'd
actually filmed a piece to camera in a
Chinese restaurant about Terry's passing
but it's you know it was a young
journalist Terry at the time was working
as the press officer for the central
electricity board in the UK and we hit
it off in a way that's just that sort of
thing we go oh you have the same kind of
mind that I have not exactly but the
Venn diagram of overlap is it was the
point where we got onto the subject of
grimoires of occult books and Terry
mentioned that he had come up with one
called the necro Telekom makan the book
of the telephone numbers of the dead
and I said that's really weird I've just
come up with one called the lever full
varam Hagen Arum at the book of yellow
colored pages and his gang oh we have
the same kind of head that goes to the
same kind of places and we became
friendlier friendlier after a while
Terry would start sending me his books
to read as he was writing them you know
a floppy disk would arrive and it would
have 30,000 words on it of a novel or my
phone would ring and Terry would say
hello it's me so which is funny they
just be writing anyone somebody to talk
to so I had written a book called don't
panic the Hitchhiker's Guide to the
galaxy companion which was great I got
to work with Douglas Adams I got to
rummage through Douglass's filing
cabinets and obscurity staff ID I'd
written the whole book of who Douglas
was and what Hitchhiker's was and I
realized by the end of it that I could
write in that style classic English
humor with funny footnotes and things
like that that was something I could do
and I had an idea for a book inspired
really by reading the Jew of Malta
I've been reading Marlowe's the Jew of
Malta and there's just a line in it
where these evil Jews meet and they
compare evil that they've done and I
thought you know you could do that seem
with demons and it would be really nice
if you got demon number one who's done
lots of evil demon number two has done
lots of evil and evil number three who
just
hasn't really you know and that was this
star so I wrote and I had this idea
about a baby swap um kind of like the
omen but it all goes wrong and it
becomes a nice kid
so I wrote 5,000 words of this thing and
I sent it to a few friends to look at
and then Sandman and books of magic took
over my life in my time and didn't
really think about it I knew that it was
a thing I knew I get to it one day and
then I got a phone call from Terry how
much later was this maybe eight months
nine months and he says yeah that that
thing you sent me are you doing anything
with it and I said well no I'm doing
Sandman I'm doing what's magic he said
well oh you know what happens next
so either sell me the idea and what
you've written so far or we can write it
together now as far as I was concerned
that was a lot like Michelangelo ringing
you up and saying it you want to paint a
ceiling together this weekend you know
you don't I
I loved Teri's craft teri became
somewhere in there before the arrival of
JK Rowling the best-selling novelist in
the UK he hands of millions of copies
millions upon millions of copies this
was before that this was you know he
just retired from the the electricity
board to become a full-time writer I
knew how good he was and I'm like this
is a fabulous apprenticeship so even
though I didn't have the time I said yes
and my life you know I look back on it
I'm just really glad that I was
twenty-seven twenty-eight when I was
doing this because I couldn't do it now
I mean just physically and mentally
couldn't do it no but I would write
Sandman
until midnight I would write the books
of magic from midnight until about 2:30
and I would write Good Omens from 2:30
until about 6 a.m. and then I would get
up at 1 o'clock in the afternoon and my
aunt's from answering machine
would have a little blinking light on it
and I would press the button and the
tape would rewind and then Terry
Pratchett's voice would come out of it
and he'd go get up get up you bastard
I've just written a good bit you know
that was so that was that was the
process of writing was very fast very
mad and was the first draft second draft
took us took us much longer but you know
we we had good omens we have this
wonderful incredibly collaborative book
it was almost immediately bought by
Hollywood and Terry and I went out and
had one of those hellish awful Hollywood
experiences that you laugh at when other
people tell you in their stories about
them because you're like it can't be
that bad it's like no it really is that
bad it was that bad
and then over the years terry gilliam
tried to make it into a film which we we
love the idea of then we were gonna do
it as a TV series and we couldn't really
find somebody to adapt it and eventually
Terry Terry and I had a deal that we
would never do anything individually on
Good Omens it had to be together or not
at all and then one day he emailed me
and he said look you have to do this you
have to do this because
you're the only other person who has the
same amount of love for an understanding
of the old girl that I have and I want
to see it before the lights go out and
then and I said okay and then Terry died
which meant that now had to become this
sort of last request and if the upcoming
good omen series is good which I believe
it is a lot of what makes it good a lot
of what because I was the showrunner I
wrote it and I show ran it but I think
what makes it good is I wasn't prepared
to compromise on it and I am normally
very prepared to compromise I'm
encouraging when other people want to
bring ideas to the table I'm like yeah
go do something fun with this I've
already done the book or whatever but in
this case I had a terry pratchet in the
back of my head who I had to please and
you know the producers would say well
Neil I know you've written this sequence
where Agnes nutter the witch is taken
out and burned and it's you know we have
villages and we have it's the 1640s and
you've got a giant bonfire and an
explosion and all of this kind of stuff
and and we thought we could save a lot
of money and do it just as well if we
had wood cuts of what happened and the
narrator telling the story and I would
you like okay and then I would stop and
I would think what would Terry think
about that I'm like Terry would have
nothing polite to say about any of these
people and it's like you know I'm sorry
we're gonna have to do it either way I
wrote it and the way it is in the book
we're not doing it with wood cuts and
and it was like that all the way through
and was like you know just trying to
hold the line and make this thing that
Terry would have been proud of I'm using
using stuff that we came up with in the
book using stuff that we'd come up with
talking after the book stuff that we
would have put into the next book if
there ever had been one and just making
it all all something that Terry would
have been proud of and it's been really
wonderful this South by Southwest has
been the first time anybody has seen
anything from Good Omens you know and we
showed some clips I'm hearing audiences
laugh it was kind of amazing it was a
whole this it does work it is they're
liking it they're loving it it does work
you should be only a very short clip but
I know the book and I'm familiar with it
and with with the work you've done or
any work or characters I deeply care
about I collect comics from my entire
childhood still have probably 10,000
polybag comics that I've refused to get
rid of and every time a comic book movie
would be made in my younger years
because they were not done generally
very well I would sort of peek through a
crack in my fingers to see how
characters would turn out and it was it
was always very stressful for me because
it's so much invested in many different
characters and just I'll give a thank
you to Hugh Jackman for getting Logan
and Wolverine right which was a huge
relief and seeing this clip it really
gave me the feeling that you'd pulled it
off that it that it that it lived up to
my experience as a reader and a listener
I think mostly we have and I think that
is a lot of that is casting
Michael Sheen and David talent were
perfect and they've never really been
any in anything before because they go
up for the same parts because they are
very similar actors and people were like
why would you cast them why don't you go
you know I think it's like casting the
same person you can yeah it kind of is
actually and it's one of the reasons why
it works so well
they have joked about and I'm not sure
if they're joking about if ever I write
a stage play version of Good Omens they
would go on tour with it and alternate
roles each that's really an idea Wow
I want to well first I should say and
and we'll put this certainly in the show
notes and everywhere else and in the
people have already heard in the
introduction where can people learn more
about Good Omens that's a really good
question well you know one thing that I
would recommend you do is read the book
Good Omens the novel by Terry Pratchett
Neil Gaiman it and it won't spoil
anything for you with the TV show
there's enough stuff in there that I put
in for people who knew the book I I kind
of there are there are Easter eggs in
there where only somebody who's read the
book will know that something is funny
or know why something's happened but
there's also things that people who read
the book will not be expecting so that's
that's the first thing
YouTube or any Amazon Prime ads have the
ad for Good Omens up the trailer you can
go and watch that it's a lot Tokio than
the trailer the trailer is is a lot of
it is things going bang because that's
what they like putting in trailers yeah
if it were me I would my trailer would
have just been sort of like you know
three minutes of two characters talking
it's like here you go here's the trailer
if you like this you like the show but I
think very wisely they put in you know
giant walls of fire and heaven and hell
and hellhounds and all of the glorious
stuff you mentioned a words
apprenticeship what are the types of
things that you learned from Terry or
picked up the biggest thing looking back
on it that I learned from Terry was a
willingness to go forward without
knowing what happens you might know what
happens next but you don't know what
happens after that but it's okay because
you're a grown-up and you will figure it
out there's lots of metaphors for
writing a novel and george RR martin for
example divides writers into architects
and gardeners and i can be an architect
if I have to but I'd rather be a
gardener I would rather plant the seeds
water them and figure out what I'm
growing as they grow and then prune it
and trim it and you know bleach it
whatever I need to do to make something
beautiful that appears intentional but
at the end of the day you have to allow
for accidents and randomness and just
what happens when things grow so the joy
of Good Omens really I mean the best
thing about Good Omens was having Terry
Pratchett as an audience because if I
could make Terry laughs I knew you know
that that it's like hitting that Bell in
you know hitting the thing in the circus
with the hammer
if you Bing the bell at
top and that's what I did when I could
make Terry laugh he is no longer with us
and I'd be curious to know how he faced
mortality because I I for instance have
Alzheimer's on both sides of my family
so I've had the opportunity to observe
people with Alzheimer's which is can be
very very difficult how did he how did
he approach is from his own mortality
Terry made an astonishingly powerful
yeah I mean he faced it head-on
and he made two or three incredibly
powerful documentaries one about
Alzheimer's the one that ripped me up
emotionally was the one about assisted
suicide it was the one about the right
to die which Terry became a very firm
believer in and made his film as a piece
of polemic about should you be should he
be allowed to turn off should he be
allowed to go okay this is the situation
I'm in and I'm in this body and I am
done and you know he followed a man to
Switzerland where he he went through the
end-of-life process and he turned off
the cameras while he did and it was
incredibly moving Terry the last time I
saw him confided in me very proudly that
he did have the death cocktail and that
it was hidden away but then it was there
for him when he was ready
and I knew at that moment he was never
gonna take it because Terry had a kind
of rear brain Alzheimer's memory was
basically okay but but shapes weren't
the physical world had fallen slightly
apart on him you know he couldn't see
things he couldn't perceive objects he
could still think straight but but all
of your spatial recognition all of your
object recognition stuff was failing and
I thought even if you got this stuff you
never you can't find it you can't get
something from a hidden place nobody
else is going to get something from a
hidden place for you and also I thought
and you've hit you now actually beyond
the point where you ever wanted to be
you didn't want to be here you wanted to
have stopped four or five months ago but
now you're here and if you're here
you're here to the end and in the few
months later he fell into
unconsciousness and a few months after
that he stopped completely but it was
inspiring it was inspiring watching
Terry talk about Alzheimer's bringing
Alzheimer's which everybody has to deal
with one way or the other into the
public consciousness is something that
was okay to talk about not as something
slightly shameful that happens to
Grandpa and also just talk about the
right to die I'm talking about it as a
human right and it you know I I really
and I understand or you know you can
listen out to me all of the reasons why
it's a bad idea and look you know here's
a creepy family and if they could kill
mum for the money they wouldn't right
now they've got her in a home but you
know they they would have killed her and
announced that she wanted to do it
herself or or whatever I get all that
but also I get that the right not to be
alive the right to end it all the right
to go okay I've I've come as far as I
can in this and and it's okay to stop
before before I become something that is
a shallow shadow of who I once was you
know that that there has to be a right
to how does it feel as is such a close
friend of his to be able to to share
this work that you created together and
really really weird the the mostly it's
wonderful and then sometimes it isn't
and Saturday night Amazon had taken over
a you know nineteen thousand square foot
lot turned it into the Garden of Earthly
Delights it has a bookshop in a corner
and hairdressers and a giant tree in the
middle that serves alcohol it has wings
that if you stand in front of them and
activates some kind of Instagram filter
or maybe it was a snapchat filter will
make the wings start to flap oh you know
just filled with wonderfulness and I'm
there and that we have singing nuns and
then a queen cover band come
and I'm looking around and there's John
Hamm and David Tennant and Michael Sheen
and all my guys from my lovely American
Gods cast come over and they're hanging
out I'm getting to introduce it's like
introducing your two families and and I
was kind of melancholy because and I
knew that I should just be enjoying it I
knew I should just be gone this is this
is magical this is this is the kind of
fun wonderful thing that you you don't
get very often in your life and I should
just be exalting in it and instead I'm
just thinking I wish Terry were here he
would have loved the nuns he would have
he would have had a great time at the
Queen cover band and he would have been
just you know grumbling to me about tiny
details and enjoying it or taking
enormous pleasure in tiny details and
you know having deciding which color
wings he liked having best whatever he
would have loved it and he's not around
and then by the same token I know Terry
well enough to also know the the way
that Terry was built and who Terry was
we probably would never have got to this
point had Terry been alive because if
you're doing something like making a big
TV show or something something this big
this complicated where things can go
wrong sometimes when things are getting
weird or things are going wrong or you
know the BBC are going a bit mad or
whatever the only thing you can do is
just focus on the outcome and just keep
going and
keep a steady course and so on and so
forth and I knew Terry well enough and
work with Terry long enough to know that
he was absolutely constitutionally
incapable of doing that you know at the
point where things any any one of a
dozen places where all we would have to
have done is just keep on going and you
know Terry would have been making the
the phone calls to the head of the BBC
or the head of Amazon or you know you
know telling Jeff Bezos exactly what he
thought of him was like no that just the
wrong thing to do right and how so
there's also that sort of weirdness of
going had Terry been around we probably
would never have got here and getting
but getting here was all about making
this thing for Terry which he also
wasn't here for which is why I'm saying
you know so so a a giant interwoven
panoply of strange emotions absolute joy
in having made it joy and having made it
for Terry because nothing else would
have stopped me writing novels for three
and a half four years but that did I
think I have to imagine he'd be thrilled
to see you in this amazing circus just
before this piece of work is released to
hopefully millions more people who will
be impacted by the work I think and I
think he would have loved I think he
would have loved so much of this and
also being Terry he would have loved the
fact that then people will come and pick
up Good Omens the book and then they'll
go and read Discworld books and that
will make Terry even happier Neil this
has been so much fun it can't be 90
minutes already 90 minutes did that that
flew it did it did and I certainly hope
it's not the last time we have a chance
to have to do it again I'm so stuffed I
would
really love to and I know we have well
let me not state it that way many many
of my fans at your fans and just as
Terry shared his gifts with the world do
you continue to share yours and it has
an impact
it helped me through some very tough
times I was able to transport me delight
me shock me scare me and take me through
a whole range of emotions I didn't at
the time even though I had access to so
I want to thank you for making good art
and sharing it with the world you've
done a great job
you are so ridiculously welcome thank
you and do you have any closing comments
thoughts remarks anything you'd like to
say before we wrap up no not really I I
I you know I genuinely enjoyed one of
the great things about having you as a
fan is the books arrived from you and
they actually get read and you know and
I learn from them because you go off and
and explore parts of things that I'm
never going into and so I appreciate
that too enormously thank you so much
and for everybody listening we will
include links to everything we've
discussed including fountain pens
including fountain pens this might be
the time to buy some stock and
everything that came up will be in the
show notes as always at tim vlog forward
slash podcast you need to search Neal or
Gaiman and it will pop right up and Neal
once again thank you so much I really
really appreciate it and to everyone
listening until next time read widely
check out Good Omens
and chat soon bye